in the last video um if i remember
correctly because it was a good month
ago now
um i drew a graph out and we worked
through it with dijkstra
and at the end i pointed out a couple of
problems so let's just remind ourselves
of those problems
and then when we talk about a style we
can see how it addresses it
the problem is that dijkstra will follow
the path that's currently shortest
and that and doesn't pay any attention
to what direction it's going so if i'm
coming down here to my end goal
and i'm starting up here that's fine if
the weights are all the same because it
will look a bit up here and
but it will get there quite quick the
problem is of course if you've got the
map of the uk
and it's searching quickly down all nice
motorways when in fact actually we don't
need to go down any motorways where it's
a country road
drive or something like this now of
course in practice it wouldn't take very
long still because
you know computers are quite fast but
the whole point of these algorithms is
they're quick
and you can imagine if you're writing a
sat nav you don't want it to take a long
time churning through roads
unnecessarily
the other problem is if your graph
doesn't look like a map
because you know in some sense the uk
road network is quite sparse right most
of the country doesn't have road on it
it's mostly fields and sheep and stuff
but
you know all houses if you have a
situation where
you've got a quite a dense network like
this
so i guess you could say a bit like
manhattan but also just
you know another problem where your
graph structure is different so if
you're looking through
an image or something like this i'm
starting up here and let's cross that
out there we are
and i'm finishing down i don't know here
let's remember that dijkstra
follows the shortest path based on the
distance of each of these
now if this is just sort of a uniform
grid let's say and we have no
interesting information to provide for
these weights then all these weights
let's say a one
so it's just going to flood feel through
here so it's going to go here and then
here and then to v3
and then to these four and so on and
that's not very optimal
right especially if we just literally
just want to go straight down here like
this so we want to build in
some kind of idea of but not necessarily
the direction we're heading but we are
at least
going towards our goal so that we can
aim for it
and that's what a star does acer is
basically a small extension to dijkstra
that builds in a heuristic that says
we're getting a bit closer
this is my our nice screwed up graph
from last time and this is our nice new
fresh graph that i've done
which is topologically exactly the same
i may have traced it
so we could do dijkstra on this i've got
my little cards but for my priority
queue
right i've reminded myself how the end
condition work
is so i can end it properly um that's
all fine
what we want to do is extend this to a
star now
a star is basically exactly the same as
dijkstra except it has an additional
heuristic
that is how far do we have to go right
um
and in this case a pretty reasonable
heuristic to come up with will be the
little
euclidean distance of how far we have to
go so in this case s to e would be that
far
c to e would be that far and so on i
couldn't think of a good way of
calculating this without literally just
measuring it
so i've got my i've got my um dainty
yeah so ten minutes vicks tend me tape
measure
which is a little bit overkill but we'll
you know we'll make it work um
so so this is all a bit odd um i don't
use tape measures much as you can
imagine because mostly i just sit at a
desk and do typing
this is a tape measure in centimeters
and inches let's use inches today
right imperial um so i'm going to
literally measure the
amount of inches from s to e and then a
to e and i'm going to just put this on
there now right and this is where you
fast forward
so i'm going to use the black pen for
this so let's say this is
10 there this is
this is harder than i thought it would
be i've got enough hands eight
a six i'm rounding up a bit it's not
very accurate uh
four so the green ones are our step
distances for dijkstra and the black
ones
are measured inches also three six
seven we're getting there six again
right that's me doing my workmans now
we've got exactly the same graph as
before but now we have some measure of
the distance
to our thing it's not a very good
heuristic in the sense that
my measuring is not very accurate and
for a star to work really well
you have to have a consistent metric and
you have to um
not overestimate how far you've got to
go and things like this but um
but we'll just hope it will work sort of
work itself out
uh you know it can't be any worse for me
you know doing it by hand anyway
so recall when we did dijkstra what we
had was we had
q here like this these had the current
distance
from the start to these nodes and if one
of the nodes would had a shorter path it
would move up the queue
and then when we wanted to expand a node
we'd take it off for q now a star works
exactly the same way
except the distance isn't what we order
them by anymore
it's the distance of the path plus how
far they have to go
so for example at b the distance is
going to be 2
plus 7 which is 9 right so b will have a
value of 9 on this q
and the idea is that if something has a
long way to go
it's going to receive a higher weight
and be further down the queue and
expanded later
what it will do is prioritize nodes
that are going roughly in the right
direction unless i mean it will still go
down really good paths really short
paths
but not at the expense of everything
else is the idea
okay so let's run through this just like
we did with dijkstra and i hopefully i
won't make any mistakes
um people will very kindly point them
out if i do oh look look check a flag
this is why i don't draw things
because it's not it's never good right
okay we're starting at s
i'm not going to draw the infinity
symbols on because we know that all of
these nodes start with a distance to
of infinity because we don't know how
far the path is in diastra
we stored the distance to each path and
we also ordered by that distance
we've now got two separate measures
we're measuring in a-star one is the
distance to the node
and one is the distance to a node and
any remaining distance
so we kind of need to have two values on
each of these things so i'm going to try
and keep the colors the same so that we
don't lose track
so anything i draw in green is going to
be this g cost function
which is the distance to a current node
so for c that would be 3
and then in black i'm going to have
three plus eight which is the sort of
combined cost the thing we're actually
ordering by
okay so the path cost to s is zero and
the
sort of distance to go is ten but it
won't matter because s is the only thing
in rq so we'll put s in the key
right everything else has a distance to
infinity so let's start expanding some
stuff
so a first a has i've got to find a
right
class here we are while he's in
alphabetical order i mean you know
what what was i thinking right so a has
a distance of seven
and a combined distance of nine plus
seven which is 16.
the same for b so again b's
i mean it's actually at the end
unbelievable um i think what i'm gonna
i'm gonna keep c at the top now because
i know that's coming
okay so b has a weight of two and a
combined cost of seven plus two
which is nine so we're gonna put that in
there now b
goes in the queue and goes ahead of a
because nine is smaller than 16.
right we're keeping a track of these
green distances but we're not actually
using them to see which one comes next
and then c
c has a path cost of three and then a
combined weight of eleven
eight plus three and then that goes in
just above eight like this
right so actually so far pretty similar
to dijkstra apart from some of the
numbers have changed
so what's next will we start expanding b
i haven't been keeping a track of the
previous node so all of these currently
let's install them in
in red all are going through s at the
moment
okay so b next we can go to a a has
a distance of seven when we're deciding
whether the path to a
is better via b we don't care about this
heuristic we only care about the actual
cost of a path to a so in this case
two plus three is less than seven so
just like with dijkstra we're going to
replace it
so a is its new weight is going to be
five
and 16 is going to be five plus nine
so 14 right and this now this path is
going through
b not uh do you think i can turn that
into a b
oh yes there we go look at that so it
stays below
c is not a big deal okay d let's find d
in my shuffled list if you're
implementing this don't shuffle it
because it will be a lot harder to find
in memory
right there we are b has a path length
of two
d has a path length for four so that's a
path length of six and
d has got a distance to eight to the end
so actually
you can see here that d is traveling
forward in this direction but it's
actually getting further away than b
so d is going to be quite heavily
penalized that's our hope so d is not
going to be expanded for a while we're
not going to look there until
it's a last resort so 8 plus 4 is 12
so 12 and that path goes through you
know what i'm just going to leave the
lids off
and that goes through b alright so we
put that in and that goes above a
because a is a terrible one remember
there's a fallen tree on that one but
it's still pretty bad and then finally h
now h has a path length of one which
is nice and quick b has a path length of
two so the total path cost is
three and the actual heuristic cost is
three plus six which is nine
that's nine in here nine's looking
pretty good right now now h goes
straight above everything
like this right b is about to pop out so
that's good
so b is finished and we put b on our
finished pack
finished stack finished list yeah
finished data structure over here next
up is h right now
last time we didn't expand h next we
expanded c next
in dijkstra because they had the same
rough path cost which is three
and c was already in the list so now
we're already starting to move a little
bit faster with a star
which is good because it means my
example's working so
h comes off and let's see where we can
go we could go to f
so that's easy i'll find f f has a path
cost of
three plus three which is six and it has
a distance to go of six so that's total
heuristic cost of twelve
and it's going through h right this goes
in
and it will come in behind d here with a
path cost also of 12.
right in general if it's a conflict
we'll just put the first one in you know
depends on your implementation
g has a path cost of three from h plus
another two so that's five
and then plus another three is eight
okay we're done with h
g goes in right at the top which is good
news for us
for our for our nice elegant search so
we're going to expand g
so where's e but i'm not gonna go off
half cop this time and finish my
algorithm here
g has a path length of five and so e
has a path length of seven see now i've
drawn this checkered flag and it's in
the way of my numbers
thanks for suggesting that right um e
has
a heuristic cost of zero because we're
at the goal so actually
seven is the final value that we get
given here and this goes through
g and we're going to put e in so e goes
in here
uh g is not really on the stack anymore
g can't expand anywhere else we've
already been to age and so
the next iteration of the algorithm
starts right
we pop e off the top we're about to
expand it and we realize that's where
we're going
and we've finished our algorithm okay
and so then just like before
we trace back through so e goes to g and
then
where's my g there it is a g goes to h
and then h goes to b
and b goes to s and s is a start right
so we've got our path
s b h g e now in this case it's exactly
the same path
as dijkstra because i picked a fairly
reasonable heuristic
right plus or minus a bit of my dodgy
measuring
but you can see we didn't bother to
expand c or l
or even consider i and j many fewer
nodes got put in the stack
in both terms of the amount of
computation we did and the memory
footprint we
was reduced and we still obtain the same
result so
there were one or two comments on the
last video about not expanding those but
you're saying that on a star you
definitely don't have to expand those
no the comments on the video were
because basically i forgot to wait until
he was expanded to finish
i got over excited and as soon as i saw
he i declared it over and we went and
got a coffee
um and yeah and that's not right because
technically speaking there could have
been a path from say f to e that was
super sneaky and really
quick right i'm sorry super sneaky is
not a technical term you see in the
literature
and if that had happened we have to wait
until e bubbles to the top of our
priority queue to be able to know for
sure
but we've got the shortest path in this
case it was very straightforward e went
straight to the top
but you can never guarantee and a
different graph will have a different
thing so the actual stopping criterion
for both
dijkstra and a star is when your goal
node gets to the top of your priority
queue
but yeah that was good that people
pointed that out because it completed
the video with a bit of extra comments
to wrap up you can imagine now that
we've seen a video on how satlab works
in terms of gps positions and we've seen
a couple of videos on pathfinding and
there's lots of videos on data
structures and things like this
you can imagine now that you might start
to think i could actually
see how a sat nav might be implemented i
could see you know the parts of the
system that have to work together we've
got a map that's stored in the memory
we've got nodes that we're trying to get
to and from and we've got an algorithm
that will find our way through
now you can imagine also
that it's unrealistic to expect a small
sat nav to completely compute its way
through the uk
like if you say i want the best path
from lands enter jono groats you might
melt your satnav
unless you do something a little bit
smarter so you can imagine they might
pre-compute some of these things like
they know that the shortest way
of getting from knocking them to london
is via the m1 or something like this
to sort of hard code some of it in some
sense uh to be honest i don't work for a
sat nav company i don't know what their
proprietary algorithms are
but you can see this is the kind of
thing we're doing we're trying to find a
nice elegant way of getting from a to b
and there's lots of path finding
algorithms and you could come up with
lots of interesting heuristics not just
euclidean distance
also of course they're going to have gps
to measure rather than your dainty
little
i mean yeah although i would say that
gps often has an accuracy of plus or
minus a few meters so my shoddy
measuring tape is actually pinpoint
precision compared to that
they'll have maps that are carefully
crafted with the exact known positions
of all of these junctions and they know
how long it takes you to travel around
around about and they know how long this
takes
because of the traffic and things like
this they're going to be doing a lot
smarter
uh algorithms than i am doing but this
is the start and you can see
you could build this up into a really
good system